who is that Carrie Hager what's up
what's Gary doing I don't know is weird
I'm sorry Howard I just I just don't
want to be involved in anything I
thought it was a mistake how did you
make a mistake I'm supposed to go into
another area where I greet the guests
and so I'm waiting to go in there and I
accidentally turned the screen on roblem
I'll recover quickly I'm not distracted
at all but Gary popping in and out of
these Jason what is Gary doing that
everyone else is not doing how is he
popping into an area he seems to have
two different setups going because that
camera he popped in with it's not the
camera he's normally on with it was like
shot up from underneath his chin up his
nose so my guess is is that he's trying
to do too many things at once and hit
the wrong button that's my guess I mean
but I don't know Jason Jason's kind of
right I'm on an iPad because I have to
go into a separate room to greet the
guests but be over here if I'm on the
air with you I see and yes I did I did
turn on the wrong button that is true oh
yeah trying to do the impossible be in
two places at once well Gary I know when
we worked in the city and we all were
together in one room remember we put a
note on your computer that said slow
down you don't see it every day
you saw it I'm wondering in quarantine
do you have that slow down note on your
desk right up here in my head our well
maybe write it down slow down
and put it right up on that iPad that
iPad okay you want me to remind him once
a day Howard you know Jason that's I
know Billy did this started so could you
say - Gary slow down slow down
make sure your stickers on your iPad
deep breath all right leave Gary alone
was one little mistake probably it's a
hangover you know he's been drinking a
lot he says he doesn't drink during the
week though yeah well I wasn't drinking
I knocked over an empty tequila bottle
on my keypad I am so sorry I apologize
hmm Gary puppet yeah do you have your
little post-it note that says slow down
on your computer
looking for it
I'm looking for or horn it's not down
there
hold on I gotta go into the other room
excuse me excuse me
Oh Jerry Seinfeld did you see my post-it
note no no I I don't know what it is I'm
sorry ask Tracy remind me
you